this is a country that does have
institutions it's not Libya it's have a
constitutional process in which people
have talked about power they forged new
constitution people have been in power
they left power to others it's very
different they're not riven by the same
things as it's happening next door and
it is an example of how terror can
strike anywhere and I think if there is
a resilient country in the region it's
Tunisia but that may be one of the
reasons of course that it's a target but
you heard what decided an issue was
saying that you know there is
instability on the border particularly
in Libya and no sign as far as I can
tell that she's going to get what she
wants which is some kind of stability
restored there I think the attack will
seek if anyone needs any further
reminder to to demonstrate just how
widespread this threat is I was in
office when there was the attack in
Algeria on the in Amenas plant which
came from the Sahel it's an unstable
region and even the most secure
countries and Algeria was seen as a very
secure security minded country and
Tunisia with its stable democracy are
seen as targets it just shows the extent
of the threat and I suspect you will
hear from the Tunisian government in the
next few days a plea for countries to
recognize just how serious this now is
and to ask that all countries you know
are able to pull their security their
intelligence and do whatever needs to be
take it and do whatever it needs to do
in order to try and deal with this and
because it's not going to go away there
aren't going to be further out pages but
I don't think this democracy engine is
it is going to be deflected and they may
therefore constitute a resilient barrier
to what we've seen we know that the
Cameron government took a leading role
in getting rid of Gaddafi or supporting
our attack do you think we thought
through enough our policy in North
Africa and and in the Middle East
because it seems to believe in a lot of
turmoil behind it it I'm aware of what
we have done since the fall of Gaddafi I
think there is a very easy narrative out
there that says that when the attacks
stop everyone walked away it's not true
Libya was on the point of doing exact
what Tunisia is done there was a
constitution there were elections there
was a government but the militias there
could not decide amongst themselves on a
democratic path and it has helped open
the door for the Isthmus extremists that
have come in but there was an
opportunity and we worked solidly as we
continue to do with those in Libya
looking for exactly what the what the
Tunisian MP was saying we've worked with
those in Tunisia the United Kingdom is
very active what I think no one was able
to contemplate at the time was just how
serious hijacking threat of the
opportunity for democracy that we have
seen the Islamist extremists did not
inspire what happened in North Africa in
Tunisia remember it was about the
economy more than anything else that's
why the plea for economic investment is
so important but I don't think anyone
saw the hijacking in as clear terms as
has now been as now being made made
evidence but we have been engaged and no
one did walk away